[Music]
Good afternoon everyone. My name is Ola
Mabad. I'm a product guy from Cisco. Um
so my presentation is going to be a
little more producty than techy, but um
uh I think you're going to enjoy it. So
um I've been at Cisco working on uh AI
for the last three years and um I work
in this group called outshift. So
outshift is Cisco's incubation group. uh
our charter is to help Cisco look at
emerging technologies and see how this
emerging technologies can help us
accelerate the road maps of our
traditional business units and uh so um
by uh by training I'm an electrical
engineer um dabbled into network
engineering enjoyed it and I've been
doing that for a while but over the last
three years focused on AI um our group
also focuses on quantum technology so
quantum networking is something that
we're focused on and um if you want to
learn more about what we do. Uh we're
out shift at Cisco. Uh you can learn
more about that. So uh for today we're
going to dive into this uh real quick
and um like I said I'm a product guy. So
I usually start with my customers
problems trying to understand what are
they trying to solve for and then from
that work backwards towards creating a
solution for that. So as part of the
process for us we usually go through
this incubation phase where we ask
customers a lot of questions and then we
come up with prototypes we do a testing
b testing and then we kind of deliver an
MVP into a production environment and
once we get product market fit that
product graduates into the Cisco
businesses so this customer had this
issue they said when we do change
management we have a lot of challenges
with failures in production how can we
reduce that can we use AI to reduce that
problem. So we double clicked on that
problem statement and we realized it was
a major problem across the industry. I
won't go into the details here but it's
a big problem. Now uh for us to solve
the problem wanted to understand does AI
really have a place here or it's just
going to be rulebased automation to to
solve this problem. And we looked at the
workflow we realized that there are
specific spots in the workflow where AI
agents can actually help address a
problem. And so we we kind of
highlighted three, four and five where
we believe that AI agents can help
increase the value uh for customers and
reduce the pain points that they were
describing. And so we sat down together
with the teams. We said let's figure out
a solution for this. Um and so uh this
solution consists of three big buckets.
The first one is the fact that it's a it
has to be natural language interface
where network operations teams can
actually interact with the system. So
that's the first thing and not just
engineers but also systems. So for
example in our case we built this system
to talk to an ITSM tool such as service
now. So we actually have a agents on the
service now side talking to agents on
our side. Um the second piece of this is
the multi- aent system that sits within
the within this application. So we have
agents that are tasked at doing specific
things. So an agent that is tasked as
doing impact assessment doing testing
doing uh reasoning around uh potential
failures that could happen in the in the
network. And then the third piece of
this is where we're going to spend some
of the time today, which is network
knowledge graph. So we have a a the
concept of a digital twin in this case.
So what we're trying to do here is to
build a twin of the actual production
network. And that twin includes a
knowledge graph plus a set of tools to
execute test testing. And so um we're
going to dive into that in a little bit.
But before we go into that, I I we we
had this challenge of okay, we want to
build a representative representation of
the actual network. How are we going to
do this? Um because if you know
networking pretty well, networking is a
very complex uh technology. You have a
variety of vendors in the customers
environment, variety of devices,
firewalls, switches, routers and so on.
And all of these different devices are
spitting out data in different formats.
So the challenge for us was how can we
create a representation of this real
world network using knowledge graphs in
a data schema that can that can be
understood by agents. And so the goal
was for us to create this ingestion
pipeline that can represent the network
in such a way that agents can take the
the right actions in a meaningful way
and predictive way. And so for us to to
kind of proceed with that we had this
three big buckets of things to consider.
So we we had to think about what are the
data sources going to be. So if you
again in networking there are
controllers systems there the devices
themselves there agents in the devices
there are configuration management
systems all of these things are all
collecting data from the network or
they'll have data about the network now
when they spit out their data they're
spitting it out in different languages
yang JSON and so on another set of
considerations to have and then in terms
of how the data is actually coming out
it could be coming out in term of
streaming telemetry it could be
configuration files in JSON it could be
some other form of of data
How can we look at all of these three
different considerations and be able to
set come up with a set of requirements
that allows us to actually build a
system that that addresses the
customer's pain point again and so um
the team uh from a product side we had a
set of requirements we we wanted a
system that uh a knowledge graph that
can have multimodel flexibility uh that
means you can talk key value pairs you
understand JSON files it understands uh
relationships across different entities
in a network. Second thing is
performance. Uh if a if an engineer is
querying a knowledge graph, we want to
have instant access to the node
information about the node no matter
where the the location of that node is.
That was important for our customers.
The second thing was operational
flexibility. So the schema has to be
such that uh we can consolidate into one
schema framework. Uh the fourth piece
here is where the the the rag piece
comes into place. So we've been hearing
a little about graph rag for for for a
little bit today. uh we wanted this to
be a system that has ability to have
vector indexing in it so that when you
want to do semantic searches at some
point you can do that as well. And then
in terms of just ecosystem uh um
stability we want to make sure that when
we put this in the customer's
environments uh there's not there's not
going to be a lot of heavy lifting
that's going to be done by the customer
to integrate with their systems and
again it has to support multiple
vendors. So these were the requirements
from a product side and then our
engineering teams kind of we started to
consider some of the options on the
table. uh neo forj obviously uh market
leader uh and the various other open
source tools. At the end of the day the
engineering teams decided to kind of do
uh some analysis around this. So I can
I'm showing a table on the right hand
side. It's not an exhaustive list of
things that they considered but these
were the things that they looked at that
they wanted to see okay what is the
right solution to address the
requirements coming from product and um
uh we they kind of we kind of all
centered around the first two here no 4G
and Arango DB but for historical reasons
the team decided to go with because we
had some use cases that were in the
security space uh that was kind of a
recommendation system uh type of use
cases that we wanted to kind of continue
using and so um But we are still
exploring the use of Neo forj for some
of the use cases that are coming up as
part of this project. So um we settled
on on a DV for this and uh we eventually
came up with a solution that looks like
this. So we have this knowledge graph
solution. This is an overview of it. Um
on the left hand side we have all of the
production environment. We have the
controllers the the Splunk which is a
sim system traffic telemetry coming in.
All of them are coming into this
ingestion service uh which is doing an
ETL transforming all of this information
into one schema open config. So open
config schema is a schema that is
designed around networking primarily and
uh it helps us to because it there's a
lot of documentation about it on the
internet. So LM understand this very
well. So um this setup is primarily a a
database of uh of uh networking
information that has open config schema
as a primary way for us to communicate
with it. So uh natural language
communication through an individual
engineer or the agents that are actually
interacting with that system. And so we
built this in the form of layers. So uh
if you if you're if you're into
networking again um there is a set of
entities in the network that you want to
be able to interact with. Uh so we have
layered this up in this way such that if
uh there's a tool call or there's a
decision to be made about a test for
example let's say you want to do a test
about uh configuration drift as an
example um you don't need to go to all
of the layers of the graph you just go
straight down to the raw configuration
file and be able to do your comp
comparisons there. If you're trying to
do like a test around reachability for
example then you need a couple of layers
maybe you need raw configuration layers
data control data plane layers and
control plane layers. So um it's
structured in a way that when the agents
are making their calls to this system uh
they understand what the request is from
the from the uh system and they're able
to actually go to the right layer to
pick up the information that they need
to ex to execute on it. So this is kind
of a high level view of what the graph
system looks like in layers. Now um I'm
going to kind of switch gear switch
gears now and go back to the system.
Remember I described a system that had
agents a knowledge graph and digital
twin as well as natural language
interface. So let's talk about the
agentic layer and before I kind of talk
about the specific agents in um in this
system on this application we are
looking at how we are going to build a
system that is based on open standards
for all of the internet and this is one
of the challenge we have within Cisco.
We we are looking at a system a a set of
a collective open source collective that
includes all of the partners we see down
here. So we have uh outship by Cisco we
have lang chain Galileo we have all of
these uh members who are supporters of
this uh of this collective and what we
are trying to do is to set up a system
that allows agents from across the
world. Uh so it's a big vision uh that
they can talk to each other without
having to do heavy lifting of
reconstructing your agents every time
you want to integrate them with another
agent. So it consists of identity uh
schema framework for defining an agent
skills and capabilities the directory
where you actually store this agent and
then how you actually compose the agents
both at the semantic layer and the
synthetic layer and then how do you
observe the agents in process all of
these are part of this collective uh
vision as as as a group and if you want
to learn more about this is on
agency.org RG and I also have a slide
here that kind of talks about um there's
real code actually that you can leverage
today or if you want to contribute to
the code uh you can actually go there
there's a GitHub repo here that you can
go to and and you can start to
contribute or use use the use the data
um there's documentation available as
well and there's sample applications
that allows you to actually see how this
works in real life and uh u we know that
there's MCP there's A2A all of these
protocols are becoming uh very popular
uh we also integrate all of these
protocols Because the goal again is not
to uh create something that is bespoke.
We want to make it open to everyone to
be able to create agents and be able to
make these agents work in production
environments. So back to the specific
application we're talking about based on
this framework, we delivered this set of
agents. Uh we built a set of agents as a
group. So we have five agents right now
as part of this application. Um there's
an assistant agent that's kind of the
planner that kind of orchestrates things
across the glo across all of these agent
agents. And then we have other agents
that are all based on React reasoning
loops. There's one particular agent I
want to call out here, the query agent.
This query agent is the one that
actually interacts directly with the
knowledge graph on a regular basis. Um
we have to fine-tune this agent because
um we initially started by doing a uh
attempting to use rack to do some
querying of the knowledge graph, but
that was not working out well. So we
decided that for immediate results,
we're going to fine-tune it. And so we
did some finetuning of of the of of this
agent with some schema information as
well as example queries. And so that
helped us to actually reduce two things.
The number of tokens we were burning
because every time we were before that
the AQL queries were going through all
of the layers of the knowledge graph and
in a in a reasoning loop was consuming
lots of tokens and taking a lot of time
for it to result to return results.
After fine-tuning, we saw a drastic
reduction in number of tokens consumed
as well as the amount of time it took to
actually come back with the results. So
that kind of helped us there. Um so um
I'm going to kind of pause here. I'm
talking a lot about there's a lot of
slide wear here. I want to show a quick
demo of what this actually looks like.
So tying together everything from the
natural language interface interaction
with an ITSM system to how the agents
interact to how that collects
information from knowledge graph and
delivers results to the customer. Okay.
So um the scenario we have here is a a
network engineer wants to make a change
to a firewall rule. they have to do that
to accommodate a new server into the
network. No doubt. And so what they need
to do is to first of all start from
ITSM. So the submit a ticket in uh in
their in
service now. Now our system here the the
v the UI I'm showing you right here is
the UI of the actual system we've built
the application we built. We have
ingested information about the uh
tickets here in natural language and so
the agents here are able to actually
start to work on this. So I'm going to
play a video here just to make it uh uh
more relatable. So the first thing
that's happening here is that these
agents uh the first agent is asking that
the inter for the for the information to
be synthesized in a summarized way so
that they can understand uh what to
quickly do. The next action that has
been asked here is for you to create an
impact assessment. So impact assessment
here just means that I want to
understand. So will this change have any
implications for me beyond the immediate
uh target area and that's going to be
summarized and we are now going to ask
the agent that is responsible for this
particular task to go and attach this
information into the ITSM ticket. So I'm
going to say uh attach this information
about the impact assessment into the
ITSM ticket. So that's been done. Now
the next step is to actually create a
test plan. So test plan is one of the
biggest problems that our customers are
facing. Um they they run a lot of test
but they miss out on the right test to
run. So this agents are actually able to
reason through a lot of information
about test plans across the internet and
based on the intent that was collected
from the service now ticket is going to
come up with a list of tests that you
have to run to be able to make sure that
this firewall rule change doesn't make a
big impact or create problems in
production environment. So as you can
see here, this agent has gone ahead and
actually listed all of the test cases
that needs to be run and the expected
results for each of the tests. So we're
going to ask this agent to attach this
information again back to the ITSM
ticket because that's where the approval
board needs to see this information
before they implement before the
approved implementation of this change
in production environment. So we can see
here that that information has now been
attached back by this agent to the ITSM
tickets. So two separate systems but
agents talking to each other. Now the
next step is actually run a test on one
of these test cases. So um in this case
the configuration file that is going to
be used to make the change in the
firewall is sitting in the GitHub repo.
And so we're going to do a pull request
of that config file and going to take
that information. So this is the GitHub
repo where the where we're going to do a
pull request. We're going to take the
link for that pull request and paste it
in the ticket
and so that when the executor execution
agent starts doing its job is actually
going to pull from that and use it to
run this test. So um at this moment we
we have we're going to start running the
test. We're going to ask this agent to
go ahead and actually run the test and
execute on this test. And so um I have
attached the change sorry I don't have
my glasses. I've attached my uh change
candidates to the ticket. Can you go
ahead and run the test? So what is going
to happen here is if you look on the
right hand side of this screen here, a
series of things are happening. The
first thing is that the this agent
called the executor agent goes looks at
the test cases and then it goes into the
knowledge graph and it's going to go
ahead and actually do a snapshot of the
most recent visual or most recent
information about the network. is now
going to take the pull request that it
pulled from GitHub, the snapshot it just
took from the knowledge graph. It's
going to compute it together and then
run all of the individual test one at a
time. So we can see that it's running
the test one test, test test one, test
two, test three, test four. So all of
this is happening in what we call a
digital twin. So a digital twin again is
a cons combination of the knowledge
graph, a set of tools that you can use
to run the test. So an an example of a
tool here could be batfish or could be
routnet or some other tools that you use
for engineering purp for network
engineering purposes. So once all of
these tests are completed uh this tool
actually is going to this agent is going
to now generate a report about the test
results. So um we give it some time to
run through this. It's still running the
tests but when once it concludes all of
the tests it's going to report actually
uh the test results are. So which
results which tests actually passed
which ones failed. for the ones that
have failed, he's going to make some
recommendations on what you can do to go
and fix the problem. Um um I'm going to
skip to the front here to just quickly
get this on uh done quickly because of
time. Um so um it's attached the results
to the ticket and this is the report
that it's spitting out in terms of this
is the report for the test that were
run. So this execution agent actually
created a report about all of the
different test cases that were run by
the system. So um very quick short demo
here. Uh there's a lot of detail behind
the scenes but I can answer some
questions offline. Um the the the couple
of things I want to leave us with is
that uh before I go to the end of this
uh is that evaluation is very critical
here for us to be to able to understand
how this delivers value to customers. Um
we're looking at a variety of things
here. So the agents themselves the
knowledge graph digital twin and we're
looking at the what can we actually
measure quantifiably. Now for the
knowledge graph, we're looking at
extrinsic
metrics particularly not intrinsic ones
because we want to map this back to the
customer's use case. So this is the
summary of the of what we see in terms
of evaluation metrics. Um we are still
learning this is a this is for for now
it's it's an MVP u but what we are
learning so far is that those two key
building blocks the knowledge graph and
the open framework for building agents
is very critical for us to actually
build a scalable system for our
customers. And so, um, I'm going to
stop. It's 8 seconds to go. Thank you
for listening to me. And then if you
have questions, I'll be out there.
[Music]